uh all right
all right we have criticized all right
very
very nicely rated opponent
so let's play one against him let's go
for the evans gambit all right he goes
for the evans very nice let's see if we
can
use our evan's magic to do something
here no let's go queen b3 that's uh
that's far deadlier
all right so now he can't play bishop e6
oh the immediate the immediate knight
here all right
very nice
yeah now if he captures the capture if
he plays c6 i moved the bishop somewhere
okay so now i guess we
oh
nice he could even trap my queen maybe
d5 now very nice there goes the pawn
i capture here he'll capture here we
castle maybe some f3 action because the
king is on a very silly square c6 is
hanging so i might even take this all
right let's capture that let's play f3
okay bishop g5 first maybe
f3 let's open up the f file very nice
all right so he castle somehow he
artificially castled very successfully
um
yeah okay this is uh this is even
good i believe yeah we're gonna capture
on f6
if queen e3 rook goes back or i just go
k1 i'll go king h1 i believe
okay i have to be careful not to get
checkmated here he's uh threatening to
checkmate me so
c4 just to open up
just to open up this diagonal for my
queen d5 let's block the bishop
uh okay yeah we trade here def no we
don't no we don't
queen here
queen f6
okay let's capture this queen f7 oh no
he doesn't allow it
and now knight f6 knight here queen all
right so he lost on time but i i i think
we did very well
and i think this proves that you should
always play the evan's gambit when you
get the opportunity very nice
all right